haha and spread sure you'll be hearing
this white facility place Cairo please
introduce yourself for our full comment
conference okay I was a I have a PhD in
American
studies focusing on literature I'm
originally a professor at the University
of Alexandria
but I at the lasagna alexandrina and my
main interests in life are women's
issues because I am one but also the
current political situation in the
Middle East and interesting when in this
respect what is your interest in the
topic of the conference waiting for the
Bavarians I'm particularly interested in
the topic of the conference because I
feel that we as human beings in this
very modern age we are calling
barbarians to come and take over by our
attitudes towards all sorts of things
including our attitudes towards one
another
the other words different cultures and
religions and most importantly our
attitude
environment and the way we envision
future I think we are going more person
okay well you are in the second panel
entitled of works follow me some
house alarm to be perfectly honest with
you I thought many many times on that
question and how I address that and
simply say we are all
and because I have
keep for the home but i would say yes
well that's quite a statement and a
final question living in the 21st
century the second decade effort even
here in Egypt world is old you know
strong connections with America at this
American government and American
military we in the west walls to believe
that the West is the epitome of
civilization for you living here explain
it in America is the American Empire the
placeholder for human progress the
question really very nicely having
studying in America and having
specialised in American history and
literature and what not I am fascinated
by American
how it began you know the story of us
and them but I'm so sorry to say that i
have been disappointed and I really
would like to put for a few questions to
the American government
people about their ability to take on
progress in position I do have my
reservation
don't get to discussing my king perhaps
when I help you
for sure you give it opportunity and
you're very very welcome and will you
forward to see you next day thank you so
much